Wow it's so spooky here I hope I can hope I can capture some
ghost activity here's my handy-dandy spirit box oh look I
think I think I have something caught right now.
Stop.
Johnny, stop.
It's my opening.
Stop.
Okay.
You're too
broken.
We're good now.
Oh,
you wanted me to stay, but I can't ignore the crazy visions
of me in LA.
And I heard that there's a special place where boys and
girls can all be queens every single day.
I'm having wicked dreams of leaving Tennessee.
Here's St. Monica, I swear it's calling me.
Won't make my mama proud It's gonna cause a scene When she
sees her baby girl I know she's gonna scream Gone!
What have you done?
And you dance at the club Oh mama I'm just having fun On the
stage in my heels It's where I belong Down at the Pink pony
club I'm gonna keep on dancing at the Pink pony club I'm
gonna keep on dancing down in West Hollywood I'm gonna keep
on dancing at
the...
What's wrong with YouTube?
I can't tell if I'm...
I can't tell if I'm streaming or not!
Black lights on a mirror disco ball Every night's another
reason why I left it all I thank my wicked dreams A year
from Tennessee Oh Santa Monica, you've been too good to me
Won't make my mama proud, it's gonna cause a scene She's her
baby girl, I know she's gonna scream Gone, what have you
done?
You're a Miss Pony girl, and you dance at the club Oh mama,
I'm just having fun On the stage in my heels, it's where I
belong At the Mint Pony Club I'm gonna keep on dancing at
the Mint Maid Cafe I'm gonna
keep...
I've left you all behind I still love you in Tennessee
You're always on my mind And Mama Every Saturday I can hear
your southern draw A thousand miles away Saying God, what
have you done?
You're a Mint Maid girl And you dance at the club, oh mama
I'm just having fun on the stage in my heels It's where I
belong, down at the Mint Maid Cafe I'm gonna keep on dancing
at the Mint Maid Cafe I'm gonna keep on dancing down in West
Hollywood I'm gonna keep
on...
Hello humans!
I...
Johnny, stop.
Johnny, please.
Go back to sleep.
I am a ghost maid.
Here in your spirit box, do you hear me?
Do you hear me?
Ooh, in the spooky graveyard.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do the real spirit box experience.
Sgetty.
Hungy.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hi.
Is there a presence here?
Your mom.
Did that spirit Just say my mom.
Have you guys ever seen like the wacky out of context?
They're not even out of context.
Have you ever seen the wacky...
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
The wacky ghost adventures clips that are just like Zach
Baggins will be like...
They'll be like, give me a sign.
It'll be like, your mom.
And he'll be like, was this ghost?
making fun of my mom this is a very very belated delayed
six-year anniversary it was supposed to be months ago many
many moons ago but things got actually legends anew was on
the oh apple tater no apple tater was the ghoul boys that
was buzzfeed unsolved but i do love me apple tater clip i
love that i love it so much this is what it was on legends
and new was my sixth year anniversary and i got busy a
little bit and then um i said i will do it this week and
then i got depressed i did not have much well you would say
i say i do not have much time to practice or prepare not
practice prepare but um but um I didn't have I didn't have
time well you know I could have prepared many a long time
ago but you know that's why I held off on doing the stream
for so long too and now we're here and I'm in a I'm in a
spirit box I'm just gonna do karaoke and in about maybe 45
minutes we will have a big could it be.
Whatever could it be.
There is an announcement.
There is.
Is there an announce, not just an announce, but also a mint
announcement.
That's me.
And we will, I will show you the thing in about 45 minutes.
So let's sing until then.
And we're just gonna, we're just gonna, we're just gonna
have a good time thank you so much guys for all the we're
all the gifted thank you so much i really really appreciate
it thank you thank you very very very much i'm i'm singing i
i would say i have anything but i don't i i just i i'm
really sorry guys i um i've i had I didn't really get out of
bed the past two days so I'm just kind of here thank you
thank you guys thank you thank you thank you well we'll sing
we'll sing because this is a karaoke stream and and and um
and I want to sing thank you
Let's see, let's see I'm just gonna sing whatever I want So
I hope you guys Don't mind so much Yay y'all
Let's see Let's do We'll just We'll just We'll warm up.
We'll warm up.
For some reason, I'm so nervous.
Almost heaven.
West Virginia.
Johnny.
Blue Ridge Mountain.
Shenandoah River.
Life is all there.
Older than the trees.
Younger than the mountains.
Like a breeze, country rolls Take me home To the place West
Virginia
Memories Gather round her Minors lady Stranger to blue water
Yes?
Dark and dusty Painted on the sky Misty taste of moonshine
Teardrop and I Country rules Take me home To the place,
don't bite that face I belong Must be Junior Her
voice in the morning Now she calls me The radio reminds
me Driving down the road That I should have and home
yesterday yesterday country roads take me home
are we live johnny stop it i fed you earlier i gave you so
much snack are we okay are we okay are we okay are we okay
are we okay and I can't tell if I'm loading or if I'm live
or not.
No!
I still have you, but in 144p!
What's going on?
I just realized my zipper's down!
Good thing nobody's here.
Good thing you guys can't see it.
144 feet no I wonder what's wrong Johnny stop it, please I
don't Should I save my announcement for another day when the
when the Stop it When it's better?
Should we do this part two another time?
I wonder Johnny you're being a bad boy
Does this go for her?
Yeah, it's a YouTube side.
My side is totally fine.
You guys want to hear Johnny?
Oh, sorry about that.
Are you going to be good now?
Sometimes my cats hate my singing.
The baby.
He's my little baby.
Okay.
I guess we'll keep trying.
I guess we'll keep singing.
Or something.
Purr like an A-Ted.
He's got a mighty purr.
He's got a mighty purr because there's not a lot going on in
his head that...
Sorry, this is a disaster!
Hold on, I'm gonna go feed him!
Johnny!
Johnny, come on!
You were not like this!
Just 10 minutes ago!
I'll be right back.
Come on, man!
Come on!
That is...
Who...
Goodness gracious!
So...
Okay.
Ah!
Let's try.
Sorry.
If there's anything wrong with my upload speed, you can
blame my internet.
I don't have nothing.
I've never touched anything on my back end.
Hmm.
You got the fiber?
I don't have fiber.
That's the issue.
I don't have fiber anymore in my...
New place, yeah.
Never touch the back end of OBS, don't get it twisted.
YouTube's problem since many of us are experiencing it.
Is that how that works?
I'm just gonna keep singing so I don't feel sad.
Sorry.
Maybe I shouldn't have streamed today.
Sorry, I'm looking for a song.
Sorry, it's so awkward.
Let's see.
Give suggestion.
I'll sing whatever today.
Harvest moon!
That's a good one because it's fall now.
Let's sing, sing, sing.
Harvest the moon!
Just
like children sleeping, We could dream this night away.
But
there's a full moon rising Let's go dancing in the light
Where
the music's playing Let's go out and feel
On this harvest moon When
we were strangers I watched you from afar I loved
you with all my heart
Now it's getting late And the moon is...
See it shining in your eyes I
wanna see you dance again Oh!
Because I'm still in love with you Oh, and this harvest moon
Cause
I'm still in love
Harvest Moon
Weehee Woohoo Woohoo Hey y'all Hey y'all Oh, why don't I
sing that?
Hey y'all Explicit?
Oh, my baby, don't mess around because she loves me so, and
this I know for sure.
What does she really want me?
Both the times don't mean to walk out the door.
Don't try to fight the feeling because the thought alone is
killing me right now.
Thank God for mom and dad for sticking to me.
together
always better when there's feelings and blah blah they say
it's nothing as forever oh my gosh johnny makes so many oh
my god why are you here why are you why you why are you in
here sorry
stop uh
i'm sorry don't want to meet your mama Just want to make
you.
Oh, I'm
being so obnoxious right now.
Shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it,
shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it.
shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it,
shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it, it, it,
it, it, it, it, it,
it, it, it, it, that was something, holy,
Let's just forget that one happened.
What was he even doing?
He likes to climb on me and he was trying to climb on my
shoulders and climb on my head.
He was climbing everywhere!
Wait a second.
I want to listen to this one real quick.
Never mind, I don't know this one.
I thought I did, but I don't.
Hello?
Freaky.
Freaky, freaky!
Hello?
Hi!
Hello!
I thought I heard something.
Hi!
Oh
Strange creature
Break stuff by limp whiskey, okay
It's one of those days when you don't want to wake up
Everything is fucked, everybody sucks You don't really know
why But you want to justify Ripping someone's head off And
if you interact, your life is on contract!
Your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker!
It's just one of those days It's all about that he says she
says bullshit I think you better quit letting shit slip Or
you'll be leaving with a bad lip It's all about that he says
she says bullshit I think you better quit talking that shit
It's just one of those days Feeling like a freight train
First one to complain lives with a blessing I'm right, I'm a
maniac, you better watch your back, because I'm fucking at
the program.
And if you're stuck up, you just looked up, next in line to
get fucked up, your best bet is to stay away, motherfuckers!
It's all about the he says she says bullshit.
I think you better quit, let shit slip, or you'll be leaving
with a bad lip.
It's all about the he says she says bullshit.
I think you better quit, talking that shit, fuck.
I feel like she My suggestion is to keep your distance
Because right now I'm dangerous We've all felt like she I've
been treated like she All those motherfuckers That I want to
step up Chainsaw As going this way I just might Break
something tonight I pack a chainsaw I'll skin your ass
around And if I don't My daycare's going this way and just
make...
Break something tonight!
I'm like a chainsaw!
I'll skin your eyes through!
And if my daycare's going this way just might break your
fucking face!
So come and get it!
It's all about the he says, she says, bullshit I think you
better quit, let your shit slip And you'll be little with a
fat lip!
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit!
I think you better quit, knocking that shit off!
So come and get it.
It's been a while since I've done now at the one I guess so.
Yay!
It's been a little bit a little while since I've done that
one.
Yay!
Meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow Oh my gosh.
I went to the store to And you know what was playing on the,
what's it called?
You know what it was playing on the thing was the, was, it
was in Da Miao Miao version, but it was Billy Eilish the, I
don't know the words.
I only know.
Miao, Miao, Miao, Miao, Miao, Miao,
Miao, Miao, Miao, Miao.
Thank you for the ride.
Oh,
big yo, big shake.
I don't know the original though yeah what was I made for
what was I made for oh and then you know what else I also
did I was like I should get out of my maid cafe because I
was like yesterday I was like I have to stream tomorrow I
have to be a little I have to get out my maid cafe so I can
try and get myself out of this slump a little bit and uh um
i went and i went and saw i went and i went and saw resident
evil i really liked it did anybody else go and see resident
evil movie yard i know i'm sure some of you have i really
liked it it's really funny yeah
a few things that I mean like so you know it's like supposed
to take place at the beginning of like the everything going
down you know in Raccoon City obviously I won't say any
spoilers and you guys should not either but I was still kind
of you know I was like it's not gonna it's not gonna have a
happy ending because of it you know everything is going to
the poo poo in Raccoon City Oh
I I would recommend it though I would recommend it I think
it's really, I think it's fun It's got a little bit of scare
And it's got lots of good humor Um I would recommend it I
think it's very fun to see The ending fits the game so I'm
cool with it No I agree And it had like you know some little
it'll have like a little easter egg like it'll have like the
the spray cans that have like the medicine on it you know
like things like that that i was like oh and like the keys
and everything and um i think it was really really good whoa
it's i think it was good um i think i think so there's like
a cop character in it i feel like she could have said
something like yeah well you're having a better day than the
newbie we got in today or something like that like a little
you know i know some people were like oh there's no leon
kennedy or no chris what am i gonna do in my evil movie i
think they could have had like a little one-liner to to to
reference him tiny bit that's my one thing tiny but you know
it wasn't a big deal it wasn't it wasn't a big deal at all
much it didn't need them honestly so i didn't have but you
know what they could have added to actually no i lie they
need leon kennedy being like i died oh my name's leon
kennedy and oh i can't believe i just died have you guys
seen those edits i mean they're real but like
Oh, I can't believe I died.
Won't you restart the game?
No, Leon didn't twerk in the movie, one out of five.
So true.
No, I think it was really great.
I think it was really fun.
And I think you should go see it.
I mean, I'm not a huge fan of Resident Evil.
people that know way more than me but i would still
recommend it i still think of you know even as a not like as
i know like you know i know a little bit and as somebody who
is like a casualish fan um you can go and still watch it and
still enjoy it yeah and then i saw oh my gosh so there's
like there's like Oh, I don't know if it's a spoiler.
Is talking about the zombies spoiler?
Hmm.
Yeah, you don't need to know anything.
Truly, you really don't.
You really don't.
You can just go in as anything.
Which I think is really good for like a video game movie
too, you know?
Okay.
There are zombies!
Well, okay, I'll say there's like a couple zombies that are
like legs and bodies kind of mesh together and they like
cartwheel along together.
And I saw some behind the scenes of it, of the movie, where
they got actual, they had like four or five people all
strapped together, all cartwheeling together to get that
mocap.
Isn't that crazy?
It's so crazy!
yeah that's sick it was so awesome i don't know if it was
like you know practical effects entirely but they yeah the
katamari was yeah yeah yeah but uh yeah a bunch of gymnasts
yes yes it's so cool very very cool yes yes um yeah i like
the movie a lot did it piss me off yes
to i understand it had to for for the movie yeah mocap mocap
i think it was it was like motion capture of it but the fact
that they used real people is so cool
yeah i'm gonna be singing karaoke for six years starting
today kind of crazy kind of Wait, no way.
Sad cat version.
Mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew,
mew, mew, mew,
mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew.
meow so I don't know where I'm at.
Meow, meow, meow.
The lyrics just say meow so I don't know where I'm at.
Meow, meow.
That's Johnny outside the door being like, when will I be
fed?
That's actually the lyrics in Cat.
It's like, when will I be fed?
Cause I, cause I, I don't know when I'll be fed.
Thanks for the rain.
Hello, hello, hello.
I have an announcement to be made soon.
But I feel like I should sing more songs.
Today's stream might be a little bit shorter.
Just because, you know, I have...
It's a stream for six years.
And...
I think it's kind of crazy that I'm still around.
think oh wow i can't believe i'm still here i can't believe
you guys are still here
uh you know because with uh with with you know i had i had
made some videos but i hadn't ever streamed before or
anything so i just kind of i just kind of took a chance with
it I told nobody.
I told none of my friends.
Most of my friends didn't even know that I was streaming
until I joined Heaven.
Then they started messaging me being like, What?
So all on my own.
Little old me.
In my closet.
Now I'm back in a closet.
Kind of crazy.
I'm back in a closet
I'm enjoying it So it's kind of A nice circle You know I
would say this year Has been a really A really tough year A
really tumultuous year So much has happened Behind the
scenes that I cannot say even a minuscule about and nor
would I want to tell you guys either but I think it had you
know chipped and chipped and chipped away at me at my
confidence I think this year is truly like the year that I
feel it's got this is so bad to talk about on my on like I'm
supposed to be a six-year anniversary stream uh i think this
year was the year that i thought the most that i would stop
um with everything which is so sad because you know i really
enjoy streaming and i i just joined the idol group and
that's not any of the problem at all so don't real don't
think that densetsu is a problem at all or anything six-year
survival stream so true but
yeah just a lot happened behind scene that made me kind of
wonder you know my chip away at my confidence wonder if I'm
if I this is so funny I look so stupid and I'm talking about
I'm talking about this oh
but but you know yeah just a lot of my self-confidence a lot
of my self-worth I've questioned a lot of things about about
how if I'm you know good at anything
I think you guys are stuck with me for a little while
longer, probably.
So, I hope you guys don't mind if I stick around a little
longer, hopefully.
I'm stuck with us No, you're stuck with me I'm the one
haunting here
Moved out to a new city June is dawning down on me and all
That I can find A sickly romance in the air Love or stroll
without a care inside Ooh, this can't be right Cause the
sun's engaged in the sky And my best friends found a new guy
I'm only getting older to cry on someone to come I
everybody's falling in love and I'm falling behind
Let's sing this one out Romito with love Touch the ocean
fell right and stepped outside and burned my skin my life
won't go my
In my room, hope that I'll find someone to do your love
Because the sun's engaged in the sky And my best friends
found a new guy I'm only getting older I've never had a
shoulder to cry on Someone to call mine in love and i'm
falling behind everybody's falling in love everybody's
falling in love
everybody's falling in love but
me well yay let's sing um two or three more songs Then I
will let Ned make the announcement!
Couple more songs on that announcement.
How does that sound good?
This one I want to sing.
My own selfish desire.
Yeah, okay.
I know people like hearing this one too.
And I like singing it.
I was the one who had it all I was the master of my fate I
never needed anybody in my life I learned the truth too late
Paul never shake away the pain I close my eyes and she's
still there I let her steal into my melancholy heart It's
more than I can bear Now I know she'll never leave me Even
as she runs away She will still torment me Cold me, hurt me,
boo me what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower waiting by an open door.
Sorry, my voice did not go today.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in and be with me
forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love.
of the light though she's already flown so far beyond my
reach she's never out of sight now I know she'll never leave
me even as she fades from view she will still inspire me be
a part of everything I do Voicing at my lonely tower Waiting
by an open door How full myself shall walk right in And as
the long, long nights begin I'll think of all that might
have been Waiting here for
Emo!
My voice today, oh jeez, sorry.
I'm
glad I'm sorry.
It's okay though.
That's okay.
Hold on, I'm gonna take a I'm gonna take a little voice
thingy right now.
Are you liar?
I'm not.
I truly am not.
I think if you have heard previous versions of me singing
that, I think you can know probably that.
I'll...
That...
I've sung it better in the past.
I really like Olivia Rodrigo's new album.
I've been trying to learn the songs from it.
Fishhide keeps making me think of mine.
monitoring.
See, my voices just crack.
.
Hmm.
This is my favorite song from her new album.
I like a...
I like...
Wait, what is it?
Olivia Rodrigo.
I like a stupid song.
That might be my favorite from the new album.
You like the fish eye or what fish eye?
What fish eye?
I'm coming to you through the spirit box can you hear me oh
my gosh
stupid vtuber like stupid song you're stupid you're stupid
you're Stupid.
You're stupid.
I'm stupid.
If I'm so stupid, why are you watching me, stupid?
If I'm so dumb, what?
You want to feel smart?
Are you watching me so you can feel good?
And I feel, I mean, I'm stupid and you feel good?
We're stupid.
We're all stupid.
I'm gonna listen to this one real quick
I'll sing this one next time I don't think I remember it
well enough I want to sing another song doll I want to sing
some dolly
I'll do dolly's version I'll do dolly's version
I'm a secret genius.
Darn tootin.
I was like, here you come again is the one I want to sing,
but I don't know if I can sing it well.
Because I don't know if I remember it so well.
Let me try.
Just when I've begun to get myself together You waltz right
through the door Just like you've done before I don't
remember it well enough I'll round your little finger Here
you come again Just when I'm about to make it work without
you into my eyes reply those pretty lies and pretty soon I'm
wondering how I came to doubt you, oh you gotta do it, I
don't know this part, sorry, I give up I give up
This is actually my favorite version of this song I love
this version so much actually, wait Did I do the right one?
Let's do this one instead.
Sorry.
This is my favorite version of the song.
Even above the remake.
Not remake, but...
What was her name?
If I should stay, I would only be in your way.
So I'll go But I know And I'll think of you Each step of the
way And I will always
love you
Sweet memories That's all I am taking with me Goodbye Not
actually Please don't cry We both know that I'm not what you
need And I will always love you I will always love you
I hope life treats you kind And I hope you have all that you
ever dreamed of And I wish you joy and happiness.
But above all this, I wish you love.
And I will always, always
love you.
Love you.
Something
happened before my announcement
Something fun before my announcement Something fun before my
announcement Something fun, something fun Something fun,
hurry, hurry Hurry, hurry Hurry Hurry,
Barbie girl I'm a believer I'm a believer the...
Wait.
Um...
This one?
Shrink?
Bum-bum-bum-bum!
A love was only true in fairy tales meant for someone else
but not for me love was out to get me I
dream And then I saw her
wanting sunshine, I got rain
Not a truce, I'm
down if I try
I wasn't used to trying All you get is pain When I wanted
sunshine, I got rain Then I saw her face Not
a truce Down in my mind,
not a truce I'm
a believer, not
a trace.
I
think we know what this music means!
The announcement is imminent!
It's not pee-pee music.
It's farting music.
The song is called the World Farting Contest.
When was the disannouncement music?
Because I don't know how to do anything seriously.
I don't know!
Oh!
You can feel your brain smoothing.
Are you guys ready for the announcement?
Three!
Two!
Oh!
Three!
Two!
One!
I'm already a demon!
Next week, October 1st!
October 1st, my birthday!
3D birthday live!
Live, live!
Like I have to go, I have to go there!
Everything live, live, live!
And I will have some guests!
Yeah!
I will have a few guests too!
And also...
Cool?
That doesn't look like my actual, my normal 3D.
That doesn't look like my normal 3D outfit.
Yes!
New, brand new for 3D.
I mean, for new outfit for 3D.
I will be debuting.
You guys have been feeling a little demonic.
lately not for three no it's new 3d outfit completely new
never been seen before outfit yeah yeah yeah yeah
so be sure to watch it because it's very very very cute
super duper cute outfit
So I better see you all there!
I better see you all there!
Okay!
Isn't the...
Art so cute so far?
Oh, you can even see a little bit of it.
Ooh!
Get excited!
And, yeah, uh...
It will be...
October...
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
It will be October 1st!
Hold on.
I want to make sure I get the times right.
October 1st?
4pm PST?
7pm EST?
11pm GMT?
8am?
JST next day?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all those times i will have
the waiting room up right after stream look how cute the
outfit looks so far i'm already achieving
yeah please look forward to it i've been working my booty
off for this I have been learning every day dances and songs
and dancing and song.
So I have been working my booty off.
And I'm excited that you guys will see with also my guests.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes.
And I hope to see lots of really cute art of the outfit too
once it is.
is debuted because it's so cute.
Dancing songs, songs and dancing.
Quite everything, quite literally everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yippee!
New outfit.
Brand new 3D.
I wish I could show you now.
It's so cute.
Any guest appearances?
Yes, I said so!
Guests, I will have three guests.
Three guests for it.
Yeah.
Three.
My birthday.
October 1st.
4 p.m.
PST, 7 p.m.
EST, 11 p.m.
GMT, 8 AM, plus 1.
JST!
A new outfit!
And then the day after we'll play Ace Combat.
Yeah.
Should we keep singing or...
Thank you.
That's enough funny business.
business quit clowning around quit clowning around everybody
yeah that's enough that's enough that's enough no more
clowning is there a song about clowns I don't know any songs
about
I only know insane clown posse magnets what do those mean
can we pretend that magnets are magical because I don't know
how they work how they work how they work how do they work
how do they work
How did they, what is that song?
What's her name?
Haley Williams?
Oh yeah, I found it.
Can we pretend that airplanes deny sky like shooting stars?
I could really use a wish right now, wish right now, wish
right now.
Can we pretend that airplanes and the night sky are like
shooting stars?
I could really use a wish right now, wish right now, wish
right now.
Yeah!
I could use a dream or a genie or a wish to go back to a
place much simpler than this Cause after all the partying
and smashing and crashing And all the glitz and glam and the
fashion And all the pandemonium and all the madness where
you fade to the blackness and when you staring up at that
phone in your lap and you hoping but then people never call
you back but that's just how the story unfolds you get
another hand soon after you fold and then your plans unravel
and they're saying what you would wish for if you had one
chance so airplane, airplane, sorry I'm late I'm on my way
so don't close that gate if I don't make that then I switch
my plate and I'll be right back at the by the end of the
night Shooting stars, shooting stars.
Wish right now, wish right now, wish right now.
Can we pretend that airplanes in the night sky are like
shooting stars?
I could really use a wish right now, wish right now, wish
right now.
I've never heard this song.
Did somebody take me back to the days before this was a job,
before I got paid, before it ever mattered what I had in my
bank.
Yeah, back when I was trying to get a tip at Subway, and
back when I was rapping for the hell of it, But nowadays, we
rapping to stay relevant.
I'm guessing that if we can make some wishes out of
airplanes.
But maybe, oh maybe, I'll go back to the days.
Before the politics that we call the rap game.
And back when it ain't nobody listened to my mixtape.
And back before I tried to cover up my slang.
But this is for Decatur.
What's up, Bobby Ray?
So can I get a wish to end the politics.
And get back to the music at the start of this shit.
So I stand, and then I say I sit.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yo.
Airplane.
To the night sky like shooting stars I could really use a
wish right now Wish right now, wish right now Can we pretend
that airplanes in the night sky Like shooting stars?
I could really use a wish right now Wish right now, wish
right now I could really use a wish right now Oh, whoa,
whoa, whoa A wish right now, wish right now, wish right now
there's an airplanes part two what else did they say i got
my wish guys and now it's time for part two and now i'm
gonna i'm gonna wish again wish again wish again i've only
heard the can we pretend the airplanes that part i've only
heard that part yeah there's a part two what does it say
B.O.B.
and Haley Williams and Eminem?
They stepped up their game.
Can we...
The airplane's in the night sky like shooting stars.
I can really use a wish right now.
Wish right now.
She's still...
She's still asking for the...
For the airplanes.
Wish right now.
Eminem.
Dreaming.
Oh,
what is this?
Hello?
Wait, I have to hear it with the...
How is this supposed to...
Falling.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's pretend like it's 98.
98.
They're just still talking about...
Hello?
Guys, there's a part two of this song.
It's like the same thing, but with M&M.
It's part two.
It's with M&M.
Well, let's do this song.
Why not?
Is this the real life?
Is this just fantasy?
Caught in a landslide, no escape from reality.
Open your eyes, look up to the skies and see.
I'm just a poor ghost.
I need no sympathy Easy go, easy go Little high, little low
Any way the wind blows Doesn't really matter to me To me
Mama just killed a man Put a gun against his head Pulled my
trigger, now he's dead Mama, life had just begun But now
I've gone and thrown it all away Mama, ooh Didn't mean to
make you cry
as if nothing really matters.
This is my last song.
Afterwards, I'll be premiering a cover.
Surprise!
Too late, my time has come.
Send shivers down my spine.
Body's aching all the time.
Everybody, I've got to go Gotta leave you all behind and
face the truth Mama, ooh I don't wanna die I sometimes wish
I'd never been born at all
I see a little silhouette of a man Scaramouche, scaramouche
Will you do the fun, then go?
Sander, boys, a live game, baby, side game, baby Galileo,
Galileo, Galileo I'm just a poor ghost, nobody loves me He's
just a poor boy Spare him his life from this monstrosity
Easy come, easy go, will you let me go?
Go, we will not let you go, let him go We will not let you
go, let him go We will not let you go, we will not let you
go, we will not let you go No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, mama mia, mama mia Come on, me, I'll let me go Me,
it's a pop, has a devil put aside For me, for me, for me
Woo!
Hey, can't do this to me, baby Just gotta get out, just
gotta get right out of here
One can see Nothing really matters Nothing really matters to
me Oh,
wait, did I have the wrong time?
Ah, that's wrong Okay, six
years Thank you, thank you Bye bye Oh, we'll raid in two
We'll raid in two My cover.
Have fun.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Wait, one second.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Bye.